la crisis migratoria interna sigue en
eeuu el jueves un nuevo grupo de
emigrantes llegó de texas a washington
del autobús y esta vez con un destino
muy concreto la casa de la
vicepresidenta kamala harris
por esos seguros gente vivo
creo que es un verdadero desastre creo
que es horrible cómo está utilizando la
gente como peones
y es que texas ya ha transportado en
autobús a más de 7000 migrantes a
washington dice la nueva york desde
abril algo que ha supuesto un gasto de
al menos 13 millones de dólares su
objetivo hacer recaer la responsabilidad
de los migrantes sobre estados
gobernados por demócratas una acción que
usa personas con fines políticos
hay una forma legal de hacer esto y de
gestionar a los inmigrantes que los
gobernadores republicanos interfieran en
este proceso y utilicen a los
inmigrantes como peones políticos es
vergonzoso imprudente y simplemente
incorrecto
una acción a la que otros gobernadores
republicanos como ron de santis en
florida se han sumar mandando a un grupo
de emigrantes a la isla de martha's
vineyard en avión una región rica en la
que suelen veranear demócratas
relevantes como el ex presidente barack
obama
nuestro mensaje para ellos es no somos
un estado santuario es mejor poder ir a
una jurisdicción santuario y sip
ayudaremos a facilitar ese transporte
para que puedan ir a pastos más verdes
una situación que también ha violentado
a los migrantes espero que
a menos de dos meses de las elecciones
del 8 de noviembre en florida y texas
muchos tachan este movimiento como el
último intento de los republicanos para
ganar votos